well thank you very much for the warm
welcome to this lovely chapel this is
actually the first time I've been inside
and its really very lovely and I'm glad
to be here and proceed actually quite a
lot of familiar faces it's rather nice
after only eight weeks in a town where
you start to see people you've met
before and begin to feel that actually
this is becoming home and we've read a
lot of scripture this morning and that's
a great thing in my opinion I enjoy the
Bible I've read it most of my life and
when you're asked to preach and there
are four scriptures to choose from it's
really quite difficult to decide what to
talk about however and as you are well
aware there's been quite a lot of
protesting going on in recent times both
in wall street and in london and various
other places about banking crisis and so
i was interested to find that we're
reading psalm one this morning you
probably know this song let me find a
note in my head you can sing it with me
well we're all neverold to freedom we
shall not be moon we're on that road to
freedom we shall not lose just like a
tree that's standing by the waterside we
shall not be we shall we shall not be
moved we shall not we shall not be moved
just like a tree that's standing by the
waterside we shall not be
apparently if you make a protest and the
cause is strong enough you won't be
moved it's a protest song that's been
sung over and over over recent decades
I've been told that it was some often in
the protests against the Vietnam War my
mother told me that she sang it in
anti-nuclear demonstrations and I myself
saying it in a protest against apartheid
some years ago now now I don't know
whether this song has been sung in
recent demonstrations or not and where
the the banks have been disrupted and in
London where even see Paul's Cathedral
have had to close because the
demonstration have made it unsafe of
people to go in and out of the cathedral
so calls being of course right in the
center of the banking district in London
but I looked at Psalm 1 over this week
and thought well when the person who
wrote this Psalm wrote it did they mean
it to be a protest song what did they
mean it to be something else well let's
have a look and see happy and blessed
first the psalmist is the one who
rejects the way of the wicked and
instead follows the way of God that
person will be just like a tree planted
by the water site Salman is not only a
psalm in its own right but it kind of
introduces the whole of the Book of
Psalms and it contains many of the
characteristics of Hebrew poetry that
reappear over and over again throughout
the book and Hebrew poetry is really not
much like english language poetry it's
quite functions quite differently in the
English language if you know your poetry
you'll be well aware that poetry is
built by playing with rhythm and rhyme
and meter and sometimes just the found
of the world I don't know whether you
know the poetry of Gerard Manley Hopkins
but there is a poet for whom if you
read his poetry silently in your head
whilst you're looking at the page you
keep noticing that some of the lines
don't make sense so have you made this
word up and how does the grammar work
there because actually I don't know what
he means but read it out loud and catch
the rhythm and the sound of the words
and suddenly you see what it is you
means because it makes sense out loud TS
Eliot was a bit the same now TS Eliot's
poem poetry does make sense as you read
it on the page but it makes better sense
when you read this out loud because then
you see that building of rhythm and the
repetition of those little tropes over
and over again while Hebrew poetry
doesn't work quite like that it works by
ordering ideas and an idea in a Hebrew
poem will be repeated or developed or it
will be set in contrast with something
quite different in order to put the
spotlight on the real point and that's
what happens in Psalm 1 first of all it
says that there will be people who are
happy and blessed then it goes straight
for the contrast they're not like this
they're not like the person who walks in
the way of the wicked or who sits in the
seat of scoffers or who stands in the
way of sinners you see that development
there sitting and walking and standing
this person who is not happy and blessed
is all over the place sitting down one
minute standing up the next of walking
about and just really all over that
spatial development that walking and
sitting standing develops a restless
picture of disorder not settled but the
person who's happy and blessed is not
like that at all but it's like a tree
planted by streams of water in fact not
just planted but if you get a really
nice accurate description of the
translation of the word
it's more like transplanted because this
isn't just a tree that happens to have
grown there this is a tree that has been
taken and deliberately planted in a
place where it will flourish it will
flourish because it's beside streams of
water not stagnant water not in the
middle of a desert but by stream of
water keeping everything fresh and
flowing and in that place it can put
down roots so deep that when trouble
comes it won't be easily up rooted when
I moved to New Haven about eight or nine
weeks ago I think I'd been here about
six days when Hurricane Irene came along
and like everybody else my son and I
went out to the shops and we bought our
canned food and our bottles of water and
then we nailed down shutters and tied up
our trash bins to make sure they didn't
blow away he took everything indoors and
waited for the storm to come and I told
my son as he must stay away from the
windows because when I've been in storms
like that before I know that the windows
can break because they'll be branches
blowing about and and so on so he stayed
away from the windows but of course I
snuck up to see what was going on and
soon the rain was sure enough railing
sideways and there were leaves and twigs
and branches you remember it as well as
I did and some of the windows in my
building did get broken but we actually
got off fairly likely we still have
power at the end of it but the next
morning we went out for a walk to see
how things looked and were amazed at the
damage that was that has happened to the
trees roundabout more than anything and
there's one tree in our quadrangle up at
the Divinity School which had blown down
and not just blown over but the roots
had come right up out of the ground and
even now that the trunk has been sawn up
and taken away there's still this sort
of stump of a route that's twisted right
over in its place and the roots are
sticking up with and it looks it's such
a sad sight to see
allow yourself to be transplanted into
God says the thalamus into this place
where there are always streams of living
water and you will never be uprooted
you'll be able to stay firmly in one
place you will know where to get your
sustenance your leaves will never wither
and you won't be pulled up by the roots
though actually someone doesn't sound
much like a protest song at all does it
that's quite interesting it's primarily
it seems a poem to call earth into a
depth of security in God but having said
that I would say that the protest song
that grew out of it is not entirely
incongruent with the psalm why not
because if this is the reason because
when we put our roots down into God and
when we are imbibing day by day the
Grace and the love and the compassion of
God and then we look out at the world
around us and we see other people who
are four crest and poor and having a
very bad time then it's very hard not to
start seeing them with the eyes of
compassion and great it's very hard to
ignore the fact that these people too
are the beloved of God that these are
the apple of God's eye that they are
created in God's image just as I am that
doesn't mean necessarily that it's easy
to love your neighbor as yourself as
matter you put it
but it becomes irresistible to live in
the justice that we draw into our veins
when we put our roots down into God very
different time here this morning and I'm
not sure if I even decided in my own
head to analyze whether the protest
against the banks is an effective one or
not but I do agree with what my
colleague Giles Fraser said in London a
couple of days ago he's a wonderfully
outspoken member of the Church of
England and he's the canon Chancellor of
st. Paul's Cathedral and when some
people criticized the Dean and chapter
of supports for closing the cathedral
and said that the cathedral was taking
sides with the bankers instead of with
the ordinary people and the poor Fraser
said of absolute nonsense the cathedral
had been strongly advised that they must
close because the protest had created a
condition of that was challenging the
safety of people who were coming to and
fro but this is what phrase is said that
economic and political justice is always
a gospel imperative you can't get away
from it we're called into life a life
that embodies that kind of justice but
the picture someone gives us and in fact
the picture that Matthew and Paul giveth
tube is not one where we are ordered to
act in justice just out of pressure or
guilt it's one that begins where we are
filled up from the roots white by God's
Spirit like jesus said come to me all
you who labor and a heavy laden I will
give you rest take my yoke upon you
because my yoke is easy and my burden is
light so when he sums up the
commandments by saying love God and love
your neighbor as yourself there's an
order to that you love God first and
then it becomes irresistible for love
your neighbor if the obvious thing to do
and when Paul said that the gospel gives
him courage to speak out in the face of
opposition and when Jesus sums up the
golden rule in the
zwei these are these are a proper
description of protest that begins not
with a sense of self-righteousness
against somebody else's way of living
but begins by being filled with the love
and compassion of God that will then
overflow to others in need so if we
don't feel compassion if we have that
what people call compassion fatigue when
we see others suffering then what we
need to do is not beat ourselves over
the head and certain you know make
ourselves feel guilty about how
unchristian we are what we need to do is
put our ribs down into God to draw on
the love and compassion of God until we
know our films love and when their
happen we will then find that once again
we are filled with the kind of
compassion and love for others that will
draw us into lives that campaign for
justice